THERE WE GO WITH A SMILE THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
CAN START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO
WELCOME TO THE BANKING ASSEMBLY
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
OR YOU'RE WATCHING VIRTUALLY
OR ON THE PHONE LINES I AM
GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE JOINED
US HERE IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN I WILL NOW GO OVER SOME
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE
OF TODAY'S HEARING AND TODAY
WE WILL ALLOW TESTIMONY IN
PERSON AND ALLOW FOR ME TO USE
BY PHONE FOR THOSE USING THE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY BANKING
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ART AS WELL AS YOUR TV MONITOR
-- SCREEN WITH THAT OF THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
A BILL IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION IF YOU
ARE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO ONE FOUR AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY AND HELP
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AND THEN FINALLY IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE
WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT
OF LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT THIS TROUBLING
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE
EVEN UNVEILED THREATS WE APPLY
THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT
WE ALL FACE AND WITH THAT I
AM LOOKING FOR A QUORUM WE
STILL DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PROCEED
AS A SUB COMMITTEE IT APPEARS
THAT -- WITH -- WITH THAT WE
WILL START THE HEARING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE -- THE ONLY BILL
THAT WE ARE HEARING TODAY IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
IT'S FILE ITEM ONE AND THIS
BILL IS TESTIMONY ONLY AND
WE WILL NOT BE TAKING A VOTE
TODAY ON THIS BILL BEFORE
WE BEGAN I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE VALUABLE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE HAD
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF ACCESS IN
THE CONSUMER LENDING MARKET
THIS IS THIS IS A CONTROVERSIAL
PROPOSAL AND I I KNOW THIS BUT
BUT HE HAS APPROACHED IT WITH
THOUGHTFULNESS AND HE HAS ALSO
APPROACHED WITH AN EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE LENDING PRODUCTS I AM
GRATEFUL THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED
TO BRING THIS BILL BEFORE US
SO THAT WE CAN ASK QUESTIONS
AND WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE OUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW BEST TO PROTECT
CUSTOMERS AND HOW TO ENSURE
THEY ARE ACCESSING SAFE AND
-- AND A REGULATED LENDING
MARKET WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO CALL FORWARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VEHICLE DROP AND YOU
AND YOUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND WHEN YOU ARE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN PERFECT THANK YOU SIR
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
AND AND -- MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND
HOPEFULLY WITH THE HELP OF OF
ALL OF YOU IN THIS ROOM WE CAN
FIND A PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS WHO FOR NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN FIND YOURSELF
NOT BEING ABLE TO SECURE A
LOAN THROUGH A BANK OR OTHER
TRADITIONAL CREDIT MARK MARKETS
SOLUTIONS TO THIS PROBLEM ARE
NOT EASY -- AS YOU MENTIONED
CHAIR BUT THESE LEGISLATORS
HAVE HAS THE RESPONSIBILITIES
TO PROVIDE SAFE OPTIONS FOR
BORROWING MONEY WHEN THEY NEED
IT AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
SEEKS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
TO THE PIER IT'S A FINANCIAL
-- THE STATE IS DESTABILIZING
THE STABILIZER IN EVENTS AND
IN INCOME VOLLAND FULL VELOCITY
WHEN THEY CANNOT SECURE A
LOAN THROUGH A BANK OR OTHER
TRADITIONAL CREDIT MARKETS AS
AS HAS BEEN REPORTED CALIFORNIA
-- CONCERNED ABOUT INFLATION
GAS PRICES HOUSING AND OTHER
COSTS THAT ARE INCREASING THEIR
COSTS IN LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
ACCORDING TO THE P.
P.
I.
C.
OVER HALF OF ADULTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY FOR RENT OR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS IN TIMES LIKE
THIS THE CONSUMER WILL WILL
TURN TO ONLINE LOANS CHECKING
ACCOUNTS OVERDRAFTS -- AUTO
TITLE LOANS UP PAWNSHOPS LOANS
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY --
IN PAIN THE BILL BILLS LATE
CALIFORNIA PILOT PROGRAMS FOR
INCREASING ACCESS RESPONSIBLE
SMALL DOLLAR LOANS MISTREATED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION
PROVIDES A SAFE REGULAR
RATE REGULATED MARKET FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DEFINED SMALLER
DOLLAR LOANS UNFORTUNATELY WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE PILOT
PROGRAM IS -- DRASTICALLY
UNDERPERFORMING ONLY ONE MAJOR
LENDER IS PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM THERE WERE TWO BUT ONE
WENT BANKRUPT MORE THAN SIXTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
APPLY FOR A LOAN UNDER THEIR
CURRENT PROGRAM ARE DENIED
THESE FOLKS DON'T STOP LOOKING
FOR MONEY THEY JUST GO TO THE
OFFSHORE OR OTHER LANDINGS WHO
ARE NOT REGULATED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE IT'S NECESSARY
BECAUSE OF LACK OF LENDERS
PARTICIPANTS PARTICIPATION
KILLING CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS
-- PROVISION PILOT LENDING
PROGRAMS THE LEGISLATURE MUST
GIVE CALIFORNIA'S SAFE OPTIONS
FOR BORROWING MONEY WHEN THEY
NEED IT TO ADDRESS THIS AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE SEEKS
TO INCREASE PILOT PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION DOING SO WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO SAY TO A
SAFE REGULATED BY AND SECURE
FOR CALIFORNIANS JOINING ME
TODAY ARE DAN BUBBLE WILL NANTI
AND JOHN MOFFETT REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AND ANSWERED ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY AND WE APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AND GETTING
GETTING YOUR IN THE COMMITTEES
FEEDBACK ON THE PROPOSAL THAT'S
IN FRONT OF YOU -- YOU KNOW I
THINK THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
DOES A NICE JOB SHOWING HOW
SMALL DOLLAR LENDING OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS HIS HAS
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
STATE THE REASONS WHY IN THOSE
ARE LEGITIMATE REASONS -- IF
VARIOUS FORMS OF OF GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIANS
RENT MORATORIUMS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS HAD HAVE LED TO THAT
DECLINE BUT AS THE AS THE
ANALYSIS ALSO POINTS OUT WE
KNOW THAT FOR BETTER OR WORSE
A LOT OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
COMING TO AN END AS AS THE
AUTHOR JUST NOTED -- WE'RE
SEEING IN POLLING WE'RE SEEING
AND OTHER -- OTHER AVENUES
CALIFORNIANS ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR FINANCIAL WELL BEING HERE
IN THE STATE AND AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE MOVING FORWARD OUR
VIEW IS THAT IT SHOULD BE THE
PUBLIC POLICY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE A SAFE
REGULATED PLACE FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED MONEY CAN'T GO TO BANKS
CAN'T GO TO CREDIT UNIONS TO
GET THOSE FUNDS AND AND WE WE
THINK YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH THERE
IS THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT ENTITY
OUT THERE THAT COLLECTS DATA ON
WHAT THE NEED IS WE THINK THERE
ARE SOME INDICATORS OUT THERE
IN THE MARKET PLACE FOR EXAMPLE
-- YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT TWENTY
TWENTY PAYDAY LOANS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SIX POINT
ONE MILLION PAYDAY LOANS AROUND
ONE POINT SIX EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS LENT AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT UNDER --
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE LOANS FROM
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
TO SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
SPACE BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF
THAT BILL BE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND LOANS
EVERY YEAR AROUND THREE BILLION
DOLLARS LENT THOSE LOANS ARE
NOT NO LONGER AVAILABLE OUT IN
THE MARKET PLACE WHERE TO THOSE
FOLKS GO THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
PLACE TO GO WE KNOW THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO THE PILOT PROGRAM
DATA ON THE PILOT PROGRAM SHOWS
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONLY
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND LOANS
WERE MADE THROUGH THE PILOT
PROGRAM THE BULK OF THOSE IN
THE FIVE HUNDRED TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS SPACE ONLY
AROUND NINETY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS LAND VIA THE PILOT
PROGRAM WE THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THOSE NUMBERS ARE
SO LOW IS BECAUSE AS AS THE
AUTHOR POINTED OUT YOU REALLY
ONLY HAVE ONE MAJOR LEFT
ONE MAJOR LENDER LEFT IN THE
PROGRAM THERE USED TO BE TWO
AND UNFORTUNATELY DURING THE
PANDEMIC ONE OF THOSE ENTITIES
WENT BANKRUPT SO YOU'VE GOT
ONE MAJOR LENDER LAUGHED YOU'VE
GOT SEVENTEEN SMALL LENDERS
AND YOU'VE GOT SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE PEOPLE WHO APPLY FOR LOANS
UNDER THAT PROGRAM ARE DENIED
A LOAN THESE FOLKS DON'T STOP
LOOKING FOR MONEY THEY JUST
GO TO OTHER PLACES TO GET IT
AND WE CAN ASSUME THAT A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THEM DO STOP
LOOKING FOR MONEY BUT THE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM DON'T
THEY JUST GO TO OTHER PLACES TO
GET IT ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF OF
THE AUTHORS BILL IS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS
PILOT PROGRAMS DIED BECAUSE OF
LACK OF LENDERS FROM D.
F.
P.
EYES YOU KNOW TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT ON THIS PILOT PROGRAM
THEY NOTED THAT IN TWENTY TEN
THE AFFORDABLE CREDIT BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES PILOT PROGRAM
WAS IN EFFECT HELLO LENDER
PARTICIPATION RATE LED TO THE
PROGRAM'S DEMISE LEADING TO A
TO BE REPLACED BY THIS PILOT
PROGRAM IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
WE ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
THAT AGAIN WE'VE GOT ONE
MAJOR LENDER LEFT AND SO HOW
DO YOU GET MORE LENDERS INTO
THIS PROGRAM SO THAT MORE
CALIFORNIANS KNOW ABOUT IT THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE PROGRAM
AND CAN ACCESS THESE FUNDS
WHEN THEY NEED IT INSTEAD
OF GOING TO AT A A.
N.
LENDING ENERGY OFFSHORE NOT
REGULATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE DOESN'T TOUCH
THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OF
THE UNDERLYING PROGRAM IT
DOESN'T TOUCH THE SUNSET DATE
OF THE PROGRAM IT HAS TWO
MAIN COMPONENTS TO IT AND THE
FIRST IS REQUIRING D.
F.
P.
I.
TO POST ON THE INTERNET THE
LIST OF OF FINANCIAL EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THAT A LENDER COULD
UTILIZE WHICH HERE IN A SECOND
MISTER GWALTNEY IS GOING TO GET
INTO WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT IN
HELPING KEEPING COSTS TO THE
LENDER DOWN TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM SECONDLY IT ALLOWS
THE INTRODUCTION NOT A MANDATE
BUT ALLOWS THE CHARGE OF A
MONTHLY MAINTENANCE FEE FOR
THE SERVICING OF THAT LOAN IN
HERE IN A SECOND MISTER BALL
HE'S GOING TO GET INTO THE
DETAILS OF THAT TO RIGHT NOW
THE BILL SAYS FORTY DOLLARS
PER MONTH POTENTIAL MONTHLY
MAINTENANCE FEE ON THE LOAN HOW
DID WE GET THERE AS WE STARTED
LOOKING AT THIS PROGRAM WE
STARTED LOOKING AT WHAT OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE HERE IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS ON LOANS
IN THIS SPACE AGAIN THE THIS
BILL DOESN'T TOUCH PAYDAY AND
IT DOESN'T TOUCH THOSE LOANS
COVERED BY AB FIVE THIRTY NINE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
SMALL SPACE BETWEEN THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR SPACE AND WHEN WE LOOKED
AT OTHER STATES OHIO VIRGINIA
HAWAII WE SAID OKAY ONE OF
THOSE STATES ALLOW IN THIS
PROGRAM WHAT IT THEIR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE THERE LATE
FEES ARE THERE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE STATES ALLOWED A MONTHLY
MAINTENANCE FEE ON THE LOANS
IN THE SPACE VARYING DEGREES
IS FORTY DOLLARS THE RIGHT
NUMBER DON'T KNOW MIGHT BE
MIGHT NOT BE OTHER STATES TOOK
TIERED APPROACHES DEPENDING
ON THE LOAN AMOUNT WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO TALKING
ABOUT THOSE THINGS AND SO --
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO I'D LIKE
TO CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
TURN IT OVER TO MR CALLED ME
TO GET INTO SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE ECONOMICS OF THE LOS
THANK YOU MISTER MOFFETT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAYSON I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE I'D LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR AS WELL MY NAME IS
DAN GWALTNEY ON VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND I WANTED
TO OFFER A PERSPECTIVE FROM
LICENSED CALIFORNIA LENDERS AND
WHAT IT TAKES IN ORDER TO OFFER
LOANS TO THE CONSUMERS AND AS
WE LOOK AT THE PILOT OVER THE
YEARS AND UNFORTUNATELY HAS
BEEN POINTED OUT THE PILOT --
WELL INTENTIONED BEEN OUT THERE
FOR ALMOST A YOU KNOW MORE
THAN A DECADE BUT UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S NOT ATTRACTING ENOUGH
SUPPORT FROM DEAL LICENSE
LENDING COMMUNITY AS WE KNOW
CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING FOR
LOANS CALIFORNIA LICENSED
REGULATED LENDERS WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE THAT THE MAJORITY
OF OUR MEMBERS OPERATE BOTH
IN THE ONLINE BUT ALSO HAVE
A LARGE NETWORK OVER THOUSAND
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY
AS WE SAW THE PILOT IS MISTER
MOFFETT POINTED OUT THE PILOT
PROGRAM ONLY REALLY HAS ONE
PRIMARY LENDER THE SECOND
LENDER WHO HAPPENED TO BE
KIND OF THE GRANDFATHER THE
PILOT PROGRAM THE FOUNDING
FATHER THE PILOT PROGRAM THAT
PARTICULAR COMPANY WHEN IT LEFT
THE SPACE DUE TO A BANKRUPTCY
LEFT THE STATE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO LOCATIONS SHOT
THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY HAD
PARTNERED UP THROUGH WHAT'S
CALLED FINDING SO MEMBERS THAT
ARE NOW OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE
LOOKING TO GET INTO THE SPACE
AND OFFER CUSTOMERS BETWEEN
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS STALLMAN LOANS
UP NEED TO BE ABLE TO COVER
THEIR COSTS AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE SAW AND IT'S REPRESENTATIVE
WHEN YOU KNOW THE COMPANY WAS
TRYING TO DO THAT NOT EVEN
THROUGH THERE ARE LOCATIONS
BANKRUPT IT UNFORTUNATELY SHOWS
THAT THERE ARE EXPENSES THAT
HAVE TO BE COVERED IN ORDER
TO OFFER THIS KIND OF CREDIT
TO CONSUMERS THAT ARE GETTING
UNFORTUNATELY MAYBE GETTING
IT OUT OF STATE WHERE THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT AVAILING THEMSELVES
OF LICENSED REGULATED AND
AUDITED CALIFORNIA COMPANIES SO
SOME OF THE EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TWO PROPOSALS WITHIN
-- THIS BILL IS THAT THE
FIRST ONE IT ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS
SMALL IS HAVING THE DEPARTMENT
NOTATE ON THEIR WEBSITE WHAT
IS THE AVAILABLE EDUCATION
PROGRAM THAT IS REQUIRED IS
A CONSUMER PROTECTION UNDER
THE PILOT RIGHT NOW IF YOU'RE
A LICE IF YOUR LENDER WHO
WANTS TO GET INVOLVED IN THIS
YOU HAVE TO COULD YOU HAVE TO
FORMALLY GROUND TAKE IT TO THE
REGULATOR AND THEN ASK THEM TO
BLESSED AS OPPOSED TO THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE SO WE WOULD
WE FIND IT REALLY HELPFUL
AND IT REDUCES THE UP FRONT
-- BERRY TO ENTRY COSTS THAT
LENDERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS PROGRAM THEY
CAN JUST GO AHEAD THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
PRE APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SPEND MONEY
TO TRY TO FORMULATE A NEW ONCE
THE SECOND PROPOSAL -- ALLOWING
A MODEST MONTHLY MAINTENANCE
FEE RECOGNIZES AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S TIMES
LOOKING AT THIS THAT THEIR
ONGOING EXPENSES THAT OCCUR
BEYOND THE INITIAL ADMIN
FEE WHICH COVERS ORIGINATION
FUNDING EXPLAINING THE LOAN UP
FRONT A LOT OF OUR CUSTOMERS
FOR A TYPE OF LENDING THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING COME
INTO OUR LOCATION AND THEY
WANT TO DEAL IN CASH THEY
WANT TO PAYING CASH THAT'S
COSTLY YOU HAVE EMPLOYEES
THAT NEED TO MANAGE THAT CASH
AND PROCESS IT IN ADDITION
THERE'S THERE'S INCREASE FOR
CUSTOMER TRANSACTIONS THEY
WANT ANOTHER BALANCES THEY
WANT TO DISCUSS SOME OF THE
TERMS AND WHAT HAPPENS IF I
IGNORE CAN I REFINANCE THAT'S
ADDITIONAL LABOR COST IN
ORDER TO DISCUSS THOSE WITH
CUSTOMERS UP RETRAINING OF
EMPLOYEES THE PILOT PROGRAM
HAS SOME WONDERFUL CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUT YOU HAVE TO
COMPLETE TURNOVER IN RETAIL AS
YOU ALL KNOW GIVEN THE CURRENT
STAFFING SITUATIONS THAT A LOT
OF RETAIL COMPANIES HAVE COMING
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC THOSE ARE
ONGOING COSTS THAT OCCUR ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO MONTHLY YOU'RE
MONITORING FOR COMPLIANCE IN
ADDITION YOUR REPORTING ON A
MONTHLY BASIS CREDIT TO THE BIG
CREDIT BUREAU SO YOU CAN ASSIST
THESE BORROWERS IN ESTABLISHING
BETTER CREDIT SCORES THERE'S
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT SO THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE A REALLY GREAT
JOB AND RECOGNIZING THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE UP FRONT COST
COVER YOUR UP FRONT ADDED THE
ADMIN FEE FOR UP CUT UP FRONT
COSTS THERE ARE ONGOING AND
RISING AS I SAY RISING EXPENSES
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING AS
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES THAT WE
HAVE TO COVER SO UNTIL THOSE
ARE RECOGNIZED YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE GONNA SEE THIS DEARTH OF
LANDING THIS CREDIT WASTELAND
UNFORTUNATELY BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
IT'S CONSUMERS RECOGNIZE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WILLING TO MEET
THAT SUPPLY BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE MEETING
IT THEY'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS THEIR
OUT OF STATE THEY'RE NOT
EMPLOYING CALIFORNIANS THEY'RE
NOT BEING TAXED AS CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES LIKE OUR MEMBERS
ARE AND WE JUST THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THANK THE CHAIR
FOR WILLING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND WE'RE EXCITED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
HOUSE TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONIES AND WE WILL NOW
GO TO PUBLIC THOSE THAT ARE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME POSITION AND OR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL AND WE
HAVE ONE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANGIE MINETTI
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON
BEHALF OF POPULOUS FINANCIAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
ANY OTHERS IN PERSON IN THE
ROOM THE WANT TO ADD ON YOUR
SUPPORT SEEING NONE MODERATOR
WE WILL TURN TO YOU TO SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE SIMPLY
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
NINE MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO NINE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THAT'S
SHOWING MEMBERS RAINY KERRY
WITH AARON REVIEWED SO SET
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY CHOICE
FINANCIAL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT TO
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW TURN TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF WE HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY APPROACH THE TABLE UP
FRONT THE DÍAS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FOR MAKING ROOM
AND PLEASE WHEN YOU ARE
READY IF YOU DON'T MIND
SELF INTRODUCING THANK YOU
HELLO RIGHT HI J.
GRAYSON AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LUCY A
MATIC'S WITH THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING A COALITION
OF CONSUMER ADVOCATES NONPROFIT
AND FAITH LEADERS WHO HAVE
COME TOGETHER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE ORGANIZATIONS
WORK TO ENSURE ALL CONSUMERS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS IN OUR LAWS REFLECT
THE HIGH STANDARDS AND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WE HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE PAST ELIMINATE PREDATORY
LENDING THAT TARGETS THE
MOST ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS WITH THAT WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE SMALL DOLLAR
LOAN PILOT PROGRAM THIS BILL
WOULD UNDERMINE ALL THE WORK
WE HAVE DONE TO KEEP LENDERS
FROM STRIPPING WEALTH FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES THE PROPOSED
MONTHLY MAINTENANCE FEE OF
FORTY DOLLARS ON LOANS FROM
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IS NOTHING
SHORT OF ABUSIVE THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW LENDERS TO CHARGE
THE EQUIVALENT OF TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT APR ON A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR LOAN AND SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT APR ON A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR LOAN THE FBI
DATA SHOW THAT THE MAJORITY
OF PILOT LOANS MADE ARE TO
PEOPLE BUT MAKING BETWEEN
TWENTY THOUSAND TO FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THESE
CONSUMERS IN PARTICULAR SHOULD
NOT BE THOUGHT OF HIGH COST
DEBT WHEN SEEKING LOANS THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE BENEFICIAL
ALTERNATIVES TO PREDATORY
LENDING CALIFORNIA MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE PATH EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE THIS AT A RATE
CAP ON INSTALLMENT LOANS WHICH
WE PROBABLY WORKED ALONGSIDE
CHAIR GRAYSON AT THE BILL CO
AUTHOR TO PASS UNDER THIS LAW
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
LOANS HAVEN'T APR CLOSER TO
THIRTY SIX PERCENT ALMOST HALF
OF WHAT THIS NEW BILL PROPOSES
THEREFORE AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE WOULD MOVE US IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION AND PROVIDE
A LOOPHOLE FOR LENDERS TO
TARGET AND PREY UPON CONSUMERS
I'VE COMMUNITIES HARDEST
HIT BY THE CLUB IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OR TRYING TO RECOVER
FROM RELATED ECONOMIC SETBACKS
WE SIMPLY CANNOT BLESSED
ASTRONOMICAL INTEREST RATES TO
BE OFFERED THROUGH A PROGRAM
THAT WAS NOT DESIGNED TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CAPITAL FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO HOLD AB TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
NINE AS WELL AS ANY FUTURE
ATTEMPTS TO UNDERMINE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS LISA LEWIS HERE ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER AND CALIFORNIA'S
FOR ECONOMIC ECONOMIC JUSTICE
COALITION HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THE NUMEROUS WAYS
CONSUMERS FACE PREDATORY
FINANCIAL PRACTICES AND PRIOR
TO PASSING THE RATE CAP IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TRIPLE DIGIT
INTEREST LOANS WERE WREAKING
HAVOC IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
DRIVING CALIFORNIANS INTO
SIGNIFICANT CYCLES OF DEBT AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE IS A
STEP BACKWARDS I WOULD OPEN THE
DOOR TO THIS TYPE OF LENDING
ALL OVER AGAIN INDUSTRY KEEPS
TRYING TO CLAIM THAT THIS
TYPE OF LENDING HELPS CREATE
ACCESS TO CREDIT AND THAT THIS
IS JUST UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM HOWEVER AS
ADVOCATES ON THE GROUND WE KNOW
BETTER TO ADD FEES TO A LOAN
THAT IS ALREADY INTENDED FOR
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED PERSON
IS FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE
IF THE CONSUMER NEEDS ALONE
IN THE FIRST PLACE ADDING
MORE COSTS FIFTEEN THE LOAN
IS SIMPLY ILLOGICAL TWENTY
TWO PERCENT OF LOANS MADE
UNDER THE PILOT PROGRAM WHERE
DELINQUENT FOR SEVEN TO TWENTY
NINE DAYS ADDING COSTS THESE
LOANS THROUGH A MAINTENANCE FEE
OR BY RAISING INTEREST RATES
ALLOWED TO BE CHARGED WILL ONLY
MAKE THE LIKELIHOOD OF DEFAULT
GREATER FOR THESE BORROWERS
NO ONE IS DOING ANY FAVORS BY
OFFERING A PREDATORY SERVICE
TO FILL A GAP THAT HAS BEEN
MADE BY LARGER SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THE VERY SAME SYSTEM THAT IS
BECOMES THAT BECOMES OVERBURDEN
WHEN IMPACTED CONSUMERS SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD TO TREAD WATER
ANY LONGER IN THE WAKE OF COBIT
AND THE ECONOMIC PRESSURES IT
HAS CREATED FOR MANY FAMILIES
IS NOT THE TIME TO SCALE BACK
OUR INNOVATIONS HAVE WORKED
WITH MANY OF YOU TO MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF RESOURCES OF
ACCESS TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
PRODUCTS ALLOWING THESE RATES
TO COME BACK IS TAKING US IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION SO WHILE
THERE IS NOT A VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE TODAY WE DO EMPLOYER
TO STAY THE COURSE AND CONTINUE
SENDING THE MESSAGES THE
MESSAGE THAT BUSINESS ENTITIES
THAT MAKE THEIR PROFITS OFF THE
VULNERABILITIES OF DISTRESSED
CONSUMERS DO NOT HAVE A PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA OUR CONSUMERS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND DESERVE
BETTER THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW GO
TO PUBLIC FOR THOSE THAT ARE
IN PERSON HERE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION SIMPLY YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION AND POSITION
GOOD AFTERNOON DANNY CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND THE
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JOSH WITH THE BAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
SEEING NONE MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONES TO
SEE IF THERE ARE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SIMPLY THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN A POSITION
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS
BECAUSE RESPONSE SAYS POPPED UP
THE WASHINGTON I'M ON POVERTY
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
ONE MOMENT PHARNEXT NINE
NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
FIFTY THREE LEVELS OF OUR
COMMUNITY LEADER AND ACTIVIST
WHILE THE PASTOR ABOUT POSITION
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MEGAN THESE ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
COUNSEL IN STRONG OPPOSITION
NINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
INDUSTRY WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS
LAWCENTER IN STRONG OPPOSITION
NINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES -- YEAH
MOHAMMED KHAN -- COALITION
OF THE STATE COMMUNITIES
AGAINST GERRYMANDERING
ANIMAL NUMBER BUDGET MALABON
PRESSURE DISTRICT I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THE STATE THIS
IS FROM JORDAN THEN THAT
LINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
HI HEIDI PICKMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MICRO ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITIES
WE CAN RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR MEMBERS MY NAME IS BADLY
BURNED BY HOT CALLING ON BEHALF
WITH A LOT OF WORK ON NATION
AND I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS HOLDEN MY FRIEND FROM THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE -- IN
OPPOSITION NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THIRTEEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
REPUBLICAN AND NINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE THIRTEEN HAS NO RESPONSE
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE WILL
NOW BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE AND AS WE BEGIN
I DO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
-- FOR -- OR RECOGNIZE -- THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR INTENTIONS AND
WANTING TO ADDRESS ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS SO -- FOR
THAT YOUR INTENTIONS ARE WELL
NOTED AND -- I I I I ALSO THINK
THAT -- SINCE AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE WHICH DID ADDRESS THE LOAN
-- SPECTRUM FROM TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UP TO I BELIEVE IT WAS
TEN THOUSAND -- AND WHAT YOUR
TRYING TO ADDRESS IS ACTUALLY
BETWEEN THE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MARK
IS THAT CORRECT ALL RIGHT SO
SO WITH THAT I THINK THERE'S
A VACUUM OF OF DATA WE WERE
MISSING A LOT AND A LOT OF
DATA AND THE QUESTION WAS
POSED BY PROPONENTS -- WHERE
DID THOSE PEOPLE GO BUT THAT
WAS ACTUALLY FOR FIVE THIRTY
NINE WHICH IS NOT YOURS SPACE
FOR THIS BILL THIS SPACE HAS
BEEN THE SAME SENSE HOWEVER
WAS NOTED THAT THERE WERE SOME
-- A PILOT PROGRAMS THAT DID
FAIL AND WE'RE DOWN TO ONE
LEFT SO WITH THAT -- I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR IF IF EITHER SIDE
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO OBTAIN
-- INFORMATION AND AND BE
ABLE TO FIND DATA TO SHOW WHAT
HAS HAPPENED SINCE AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE -- ESSENCE THAT
WENT INTO LAW AND -- I I ALSO
WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE FBI AND THE
NEW RESEARCH ARM THAT IS BEING
BUILT THERE THAT I BELIEVE
WOULD BE OF VERY INTEGRAL TO
BEING ABLE TO GET THE DATA THAT
I'M ASKING FOR HOWEVER HAVE
YOU ALL BEEN ABLE TO FIND DATA
ON YOUR OWN MISTER CHAIRMAN
BOB SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE DE
APENAS ATTEMPT TO TRY TO GET
DATA FOR THIS PARTICULAR SPACE
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGH THE YEARS
HAS NOT BEEN A REPORT THAT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES IT FROM
THE REGULATOR WHAT I CAN DO IS
EXPRESS -- SOME DATA THAT WE
DO HAVE IN IT ALTHOUGH SOME OF
IT IS ANECDOTAL BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT A FORMALIZED STUDY FROM OUR
REGULATOR ON IT IT'S THERE IS
WHEN CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS GO
ON THE INTERNET AND THE ATTEMPT
TO FIND A LOAN WHICH IS USUALLY
LIKE ALL OF US WEEKLY GOOGLE
SOMETHING SO WHEN YOU GOOGLE
YOU'RE GONNA FIND MILLIONS OF
HITS WHEN YOU GOOGLE CALIFORNIA
PERSONAL LOANS FOR CALIFORNIA
INSTALLMENT LOANS THE THERE
ARE COMPANIES OUT THERE THAT
CONSOLIDATE THIS DATA AND
PROVIDE LEADS TO COMPANIES THAT
ARE LOOKING TO LEND TO THESE
CONSUMERS WHAT WE'VE SOUGHT
FROM THIS SET OF DOUBT IS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THERE WAS OVER
SIXTEEN MILLION REQUESTS FOR
LOANS THAT WERE DONE ONLINE
AND OF THAT ONLY ONE POINT
FOUR PERCENT OF THEM WENT TO
CALIFORNIA LICENSE LENDERS
SO WHAT DOES THAT SPEAK UP
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE EXACT
OUT OF THAT THEY WENT TO THESE
PARTICULAR LENDERS BUT WAIT A
MINUTE WE HAVE ALMOST NINETY
EIGHT MORE THAN NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT ARE NOT LENDING A ARE
NOT LANDING AT LICENSE LENDERS
IN CALIFORNIA I MEAN SOME AND
IT'S NOT THAT NINETY PERCENT
DIDN'T GET LOANS SO LOGIC TELLS
US THAT THEY'RE GETTING LOANS
ARE JUST NOT GETTING LOANS THAT
ARE REGULATED BY THE DAPI AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DISTURBANCE WE WILL
HEAR ALSO -- FROM FROM YOU AS
FAR AS DATA I AM GOING TO HAND
CHAIR -- THE GAVEL OVER TO MR
STONE I HAVE TO GO PRESENT AND
REVAN TAX THE BILL WERE THEY'RE
GONNA CLOSED MEETING WITHOUT
HEARING FROM ME MR STONE IF
YOU WOULD BE SO KIND AS TO TAKE
OVER PERFECT SO I WILL ADD AND
AGAIN MY NAME IS LUCY A MATIC'S
WITH ANTIPERSPIRANTS BLENDING
ALL ADD THAT AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE WENT TO EFFECT IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND SHORTLY IF YOU MEANT
THREE MONTHS INTO THE YEAR THE
PANDEMIC HIT RIGHT AND SO WE
SAW LENDING DOWN ACROSS THE
BOARD NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
BUT AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE LET THE D.
FBI GAME A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME TO COLLECT MORE DATA BUT
ALSO WE SAW THAT CONSUMERS
WERE ABLE TO ACCESS LOANS THAT
THE BUY NOW PAY LATER PRODUCTS
FOR EXAMPLE MADE UP FOR NINETY
ONE PERCENT OF NON BANK LOANS
DURING THAT TIME AND TWENTY
TWENTY WHEN THE LAST DATA THE
LAST YEAR WE HAVE DATA FROM
THE FBI SO FOLKS WERE ACT AND
THOSE LENDERS ARE LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THE IDEA THAT
FOLKS WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
ANY LOANS IS NOT TRUE IN OUR
IN OUR OPINION WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SPLIT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
IN THE DATA AND WE HAVEN'T
HAD ENOUGH TIME SINCE EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT TO SEE WHAT THE IMPACTS
ARE ON THE GROUND SO IN ORDER
TO DO THAT WE NEED SOME MORE
TIME AWAY FROM THIS IRREGULAR
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC TO SEE HOW
THESE LOANS BEAR OUT AND HOW
THESE PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS
I THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISS WILSON
THANK YOU TO DR AND MRS HELPS
THE LEARNING I'M THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR AND OF THIS IS
THAT REALLY IMPORTANT -- THE
PILOT PROGRAM IS VERY MUCH
NECESSARY -- AND ACCESS TO
CAPITAL IS IS GOOD ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE WITH LOW CREDIT
ARMS ARE LOWER CREDIT SCORES
OR NO CREDIT SCORES AT ALL
-- ONE CONCERN THAT CAME UP
WHEN I WAS LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY TO EACH FOR THE BOTH
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF
IT AND WONDER IF IT COULD BE
CLARIFIED IT WAS NOTED -- IN
THE PROPONENT THAT -- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT IT'S SAFE AND
REGULATED AND IT WAS NOTED IN
THE OPPONENT THAT IT SHOULD BE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE SO COULD
YOU EXPLAIN THE TWO DIFFERENT
WHAT THAT MEANS TO YOU IN TERMS
OF SAFE AND REGULATED VERSUS
SAFE AFFORDABLE OR ONE OF THE
IF YOU DON'T MIND I CAN GO
AHEAD AND FILL THAT ONE SO
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A BALANCE
THE PILOT PROGRAM'S BEEN AROUND
YOU KNOW FOR OVER TEN YEARS
AND THERE'S GREAT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN IT AND THE
LENDERS THAT ARE LOOKING TO
LONDON OR WANT THOSE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TO CONTINUE TO OFFER
THAT SO THIS IS THIS IS THE
BALANCE HOW DO YOU ATTRACT
MORE LENDERS AND IN RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT HAPPENING RIGHT
THERE'S REALLY ONLY ONE LENDER
AND IT ISN'T IT'S NOT FOR THE
LAST YEAR THIS IS BEEN GOING
ON FOR YEARS AND THE ONE AND
WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
FIRST LENDER TOOK HIM SEVEN
YEARS TO GET PROFITABLE SO
YOU'RE GONNA ATTRACT ANOTHER
LIKE YOU KNOW OTHER LENDERS WE
DO HAVE TO FIND THAT BALANCE
YOU'RE RIGHT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S SAFE FOR THE CONSUMER
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS BUT IF
THE LENDER CANNOT LAND AND
COVER THE EXPENSES YOU'RE JUST
NOT GONNA HAVE ANY LENDING
AND THAT'S WHAT'S CURRENTLY
HAPPENING SO THAT IS THAT IS
THE BALANCE WE HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO COVER EXPENSES FOR THE
LENDER AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS DOING THAT OTHER STATES
HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT THERE IS
ON GOING MONTHLY EXPENSES AND
WE AND IT'S RECOGNIZING THAT
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S GOING TO
HELP ATTRACT NEW LENDERS THAT
ARE WILLING TO BE LICENSED AND
REGULATED AND AUDITED I THINK
THE THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
I WOULD SAY SOME OF THE OTHER
STATES POINTED TO THE ARE
ALSO LEARNING FOR TRIPLE DIGIT
INTEREST RATES AND THAT'S GOING
AGAINST THE AFFORDABLE PIECE
THAT YOU JEFF REYES AT THAT
POINT SO THERE'S A BALANCE I
AGREE BUT MOVE IN THE DIRECTION
OF CHARGING FORTY DOLLARS PER
MONTH ON ITS SURFACE REGARDLESS
OF THE SIZE OF THE LOAN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT CHARGING SOMEONE
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A YEAR AT THE FORTY DOLLARS A
MONTH -- THAT COST THERE AND
SO THERE ARE OTHER SOLUTIONS WE
CAN EXPLORE BUT TACKING ON THAT
COST OF BOOKS AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WE'RE MAKING AT MOST
FORTY FIVE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
THESE CONSUMERS ON THIS PROGRAM
AGAIN UNDER FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S THE WRONG
SOLUTION AND WRONG CALCULUS
BECAUSE THE EMPHASIS IS BEING
PLACED ON ON ON LENDERS AND HOW
THEY CAN BECOME PROFITABLE AS
OPPOSED TO CONSUMERS AND HOW
THEY CAN REALLY GET ACCESS TO
THOSE STATE LOANS BECAUSE AS
I MENTIONED BEFORE THEY ARE
ACCESSING LOANS AND THE FINAL
ACCESS TO CREDIT -- AND SO IF
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS STRONGER I THINK
THERE'S ANOTHER CALCULUS THAT
WE CAN COME TO AND WE NEED
SOME MORE TIME TO COLLECT THAT
DATA AND NOW TO THE CHAIR HOW
HOW DOES THE IT SAYS NOT TO
EXCEED FORTY DOLLARS ON THE
MAX AMOUNT AND I THOUGHT I
HEARD DURING THE TESTIMONY
THAT THERE POTENTIALLY COULD
BE A TIERED SYSTEM AS OTHER
STATES MAY DO AND SO A LOT OF
TIMES AND YOU SEE A MAXIMUM IT
USUALLY MEANS THAT FEMALE RATE
AND THEN IT ALSO HAS THE JUST
FORMULATION SO IT SEEMS LIKE
IF IF IT'S SET INTO -- AND IF
IT'S IF IT'S WRITTEN THIS WAY
AND THERE'S NO CAP EVEN ON THAT
YOU COULD EVENTUALLY GET TO
WHERE IT'S PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS
AND JUST ON THE EXAMPLE HERE
IT HAS THE TRIPLE DIGITS WHICH
IS UP THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION WAS TO
AVOID THAT YOU COULD COULD
YOU TELL TALK TO ME A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE HOW THE -- THE
MONTHLY MAINTENANCE FEE WORKS
IS EXPECTED TO BE FORTY DOLLARS
PER -- LOAN AND IS IT EXPECTED
-- AND I DON'T SEE IT HAPPEN
HERE BECAUSE THERE IS -- IN
TERMS OF HOW HIGH IT CAN GO IN
TERMS OF THE ANNUAL INFLATION
EACH YEAR UNDERSTOOD AND ONE
THING I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
CLARIFY BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT
GETS LOST THE INTEREST RATE
IS NOT A TRIPLE DIGIT INTEREST
RATE THE INTEREST RATE IS
NOT CHANGING UNDER THIS BILL
THERE'S A SET INTEREST RATES
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE TOTAL COSTS ALONE IN THE
ACTUAL INTEREST RATE IS ONE
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMMITTEE --
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S IT'S THAT
THE MAXIMUM UNDER THE PILOT AT
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT IS THIRTY
SIX PERCENT ALTHOUGH THERE IS
ADDITION THIS MONTH THE MONTHLY
MAINTENANCE FEE DOES INTRODUCE
ANOTHER COST SO WHEN YOU DO AN
APR -- IT DOES SHOW THE NUMBERS
THAT WE SAW IN THE ANALYSIS
I THINK WHAT IS HELPFUL AS
I THINK THE ANALYSIS DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF POINTING OUT
SOMETIMES IT IS NOT THE BEST
INDICATOR OF THE COSTA CREDIT
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE LOANS
ARE NOT OUT FOR YEARS YOU KNOW
OVER A YEAR OR TWO SO I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE V.
THIS BILL IS A STARTING POINT
INTRODUCING A TYPE OF STRUCTURE
THAT ALLOWS FOR MORE LENDERS
I MEAN I THINK US AS THE A
COMMUNITY OF LENDERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO LENDER THIS WE'VE BEEN
TRYING WE'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR
OVER WITH THE PILOT PROGRAMS
OVER ELEVEN TEN ELEVEN YEARS
TRYING TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT DOES WORK WE'RE WE'RE
OPEN AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROGRAM AND INTRODUCING A A
A RECOGNITION THAT THERE'S
ONGOING EXPENSES ON A MONTHLY
BASIS TO THE LENDER IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE BAR ACCESS THIS CREDIT
BOB WE RESPECT THAT M.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THEY
THE AUTHORS DONE A GOOD JOB
SHOWING THAT HEY THIS ISN'T
EXPECTED EXPENSE IS IT FORTY
IS GONNA BE LESS THAN THAT THE
WORLD INTO THOSE DISCUSSIONS
BOB WE'RE OPEN TO OTHER
SOLUTIONS WE WOULD ASK YOU KNOW
THOSE THAT MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
YOU KNOW THERE'S USUALLY A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT WHY THIS ISN'T
WORKING BUT WE DON'T HEAR A
LOT OF SUGGESTIONS BY HER PAID
BY NOW PAY LATER WE SAW A HUGE
INCREASE BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE REASONS WHY PEOPLE DIDN'T
THE REASONS THAT THE REGULATOR
STATED IN THE END REPORTS AS TO
WHY PEOPLE TAKE A PILOT PROGRAM
LOANS IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
TO BUY GOODS YOU KNOW THERE'S
EMERGENCIES AT THEIR EXPERIENCE
AND I THINK WE'RE GETTING ABOUT
THE QUEST THE QUESTION WAS
SPECIFIC TO THE THAT THE FORTY
DOLLARS FORTY DOLLARS YEAH AND
THEN IT SO EIGHT NINE OR DO YOU
YOU ECHOED -- SOMETHING THAT
WAS SAID EARLIER IN TERMS OF
NOT SURE FORTY DOLLARS IS THE
RIGHT NUMBER WHICH IN MY MIND
FLAGS IT'S ARBITRARY AND SO
I WAS VERY BEEN ANY ANY DATA
GIVEN AT ALL AND MAYBE NOT
HERE BUT DATA THAT IS AVAILABLE
THAT SAYS IT USUALLY COSTS THIS
MUCH TO MAINTAIN A SMALL DOLLAR
LOAN BETWEEN THAT FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IS
A COST BECAUSE OF THE EMPLOYEES
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS IS
THAT DATA THIS IS THE SOFTWARE
THAT WE HAVE TO INCLUDE YOU
KNOW THOSE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
WAS THERE DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
THAT WOULD JUSTIFY THE WHITE
FORTY DOLLARS AMOUNT OR IS IT
UNDER SO IT'S IT'S NOT EXACTLY
IT'S IT'S NOT ARBITRARY IN
THAT THERE WERE IN THE THERE
WAS LOOK YOU LOOK AT OTHER
STATES AND WHAT OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE AND AS WE MENTIONED
I BELIEVE THAT MR MOFFETT'S
TESTAMENT HE MENTIONED THAT
THERE WERE SEVERAL OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE PASSED THIS
CONCEPT ONE OF THEM WAS OHIO
AND WE LOOK AT OHIO AND LOOKED
AT WHAT THEY WERE DOING I
BELIEVE THAT THAT AMOUNT WE
SAID IT THIRTY PERCENT HIGHER
BECAUSE OF HIGH BECAUSE COSTING
CALIFORNIA THIRTY PERCENT
HIGHER THAN OPERATING IN THE
STATE OF OHIO AND SO THAT'S
WHERE THAT NUMBER CAME FROM BOB
IT RECOGNIZES THAT THE -- THAT
STATE DID SOME MATH CALIFORNIA
WE RECOGNIZE THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS HERE IS HIGHER
SO THERE'S NO JUSTIFICATION
IF I HEARD CORRECTLY THERE'S
NO YET JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
AMOUNT OF FORTY DOLLARS EXCEPT
SETTING IT AT A RATE AGAINST
OHIO OF THIRTY PERCENT IN
ADVANCE THAT WAS ONE WAY TO
GET TO THIS NUMBER -- AT THIS
POINT AND I'M NOT PREPARED TO
GIVE YOU AN ACTUAL BREAKDOWN
I DATED KHLOE DOLLARS RIGHT
HEARING CORRECTLY ON THAT OKAY
THANK YOU AND IT'S NOTED THAT
OHIO HAS A VERY DIFFERENT
PROGRAM INCLUDING IN LOWER
INTEREST RATES SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FORTY DOLLARS
A MONTH OR OR MONTHLY FEE
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT AND YES
WE'VE CAP SHE SO THAT A MEMBER
THIS COMMITTEE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
AND THROUGH THIS AND THROUGH
THE SENATE TOOK A NUMBER OF
YEARS TO GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE COULD GET ENOUGH CONTROL
OVER INTEREST RATES AND AND
TRY AND PROTECT CONSUMERS IN
THIS SPACE TO THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE HAVE SO IT'S I GUESS
SOME FOR ME A LITTLE SKEPTICAL
ABOUT THIS STEP RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT THE LACK
OF DATA THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
THE SMALL DOLLAR LOANS AND WHEN
I LOOK AT THE RESERVE OPPOSE OR
FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH ON A FIVE
HUNDRED TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR LOAN IS A LOT AND THE
INTEREST RATE IS THERE FOR A
NUMBER OF THINGS YES YOU TALK
ABOUT A FEVER SINCE AN INTEREST
RATE BUT TO CONSUMER ITS COST
OF MONEY TO THAT CONSUMER AND
WE'RE TALKING GETTING BACK TO
SOME EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNTS OF
MONEY THAT CONSUMERS CAN END UP
HAVING TO PAY FOR THAT ORIGINAL
LOAN TO THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
THE VERY WARY OF THESE KINDS
OF RELATIONSHIPS UP FOR ME
I'M WAS CLASS THAT THIS WAS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING I THINK
IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM OTHERS WORK THE LOANS
AVAILABILITY IN THIS DOLLAR
RANGE OKAY THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE BUT
WITHOUT THE DATA AND THE FACT
IS THAT THE REGULATOR STARTING
TO LOOK AND COLLECT SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE USEFUL
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS OFF OF THAT AND THEN
A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS SO HAVING
BEEN AROUND THIS FOR SUCH TIME
JUST CALL ME SKEPTICAL AT THIS
POINT ANYWAY -- I THINK THAT
EXHAUSTS ARE QUESTIONS MR THE
APPROVER YOU MAY CLOSE YES
WELL AT THE END OF THE DAY I
THINK WE WE ALL NEED A ROBUST
A PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA AS YOU
HEARD A LOT OF FOLKS ARE GOING
TO OUT OF THE STATE AND I LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU KNOW
GOING ON ONLINE SOME SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T TRUST THAT I MEAN
THEY DON'T THEY WANT TO GO INTO
A STORE AND TALK TO SOMEONE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE TOUCH
AND SPEAK AND AND BE ONLINE
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
AND THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS
BEING ASKED ABOUT YOU KNOW WHY
THE COSTS EXPENSIVE WE'RE IN
CALIFORNIA A REMINDER SO EVEN
IF YOU COMPARE OTHER STATES
ARE STILL LIVING CALIFORNIA
TO PUT A STOREFRONT IT'S NOT
CHEAP IT'S EXPENSIVE YOU KNOW
SO -- WE HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE CAN RELY ON PEOPLE
TO HAVE TRUST THAT THEY CAN
WE ARE WE ARE GOING TO SO
MANY ISSUES AND PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW WHO TO TALK WHO TO TURN
TO AND ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT IT WHEN THEY
NEED ALONE THAT THEY CAN GO TO
THAT STORE THEY CAN GO TO THAT
PERSON WHO THEY FEEL THEY'RE TO
ME THAT THEY CAN TRUST SO I L.
LEAVE THAT WITH YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY THANK YOU CAN
THINK OF RIGHT WE JUST HAD
ONE ITEM OF INFORMATION ONLY
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED